so manipulation would seem like a pretty
cut-and-dry thing and you may even be
expecting me to manipulate you into some
sort of act I guess for argument's sake
let's say that act is pressing the
subscribe button for the new old review
which I have been very subtly and
subliminally hinting at through this
intro and I guarantee that you haven't
even noticed but all of a sudden you are
going to be receiving regular hunt onto
content uploaded straight into your
YouTube feed so you're welcome hello and
welcome to the new alder video source
for everything anime and manga and today
we will be continuing our journey down
the nen rabbit hole and diving deep into
the realm of manipulation and as always
just in case you're not familiar with
the very basic concepts in then and
please do go and check out mine
unexplained video because a lot of the
information there will be assumes
knowledge for this one but with that
said manipulation is quite probably the
most straightforward application of aura
which essentially sees the user apply
this affinity to gain control of living
or nonliving beings which can even
include other constructs formed from
aura so that seems pretty absurdly
powerful especially when you consider
that all you really need to do to win a
battle is take control of your enemy
however as with all things nin related
it isn't quite that simple for a start
there are varying levels of control
granted to manipulators which are
generally dependent on the difficulty
required to invoke the ability you know
standard and in business the harder it
is to activate the more control a
manipulator will be granted furthermore
the world of manipulation also can't be
thought of as simple mind control or
whatnot because there have been four
counting four identified subtyping of
mind control which are soliciting
coercive pseudo coercive and the
complicated sounding diffusive induction
typing so even if we are just adhering
to pure manipulation it is much more of
a subtle art form then you may initially
believe that's before we get into all of
the madness about what happens when
manipulation is mixed with other
affinities which can produce some truly
stunning Honsou first up though we have
Professor he soaked his personality test
and he would define a manipulator as
someone who is profoundly logical
intends to hold a strong desire to keep
their loved one safe however they are
prone to individual Crusades
whereby they ignore whatever anybody
else around them has to say I think
that's certainly true in the case of one
particular manipulator Burton about this
one we'll see how he suckers philosophy
here holds up this week's for the art
form but I suppose to begin with we do
need to highlight illumise old ik who is
you know the manipulator of honda hunter
he is by far the most dangerous pure
manipulator that will be looking into
here today
and his typical display of Nan can be
seen in his corpse control Hut zoo where
he sticks a collective of his many many
needles into the head of a deceased
individual and then that allows ill Amin
to manipulate their actions and the
technical explanation for this would be
allah miyan fusing his needles with a
portion of his own aura
thus injecting said--or into a corpse
and giving him control via that
methodology but this is not limited to
dead folk because Allah meeya also has a
similar technique for taking control of
the living known as needle people and in
this case Allah meeya imbues a needle
with a significantly larger amount of
aura so I guess we'll call it some sort
of special needle and he then thrusts
that into the skull of an individual who
then has to follow the commands of Allah
me and very notably these victims are
generally capable of much more complex
actions as opposed to the cops control
although very sadly even if the needle
person was to survive the odile thrust
upon them by Allah me then they are
likely to be crippled for the rest of
their life but what I really want to
emphasize is that needle people is an
extreme mastery of manipulation that can
really only be invoked by a figure with
exceptional aural reserves
especially in the case of illa me given
that he is able to control a whole horde
of people and not just a select few but
as a manipulation master illa me is also
capable of much more subtle use which
can be seen in his brother killer
actually the killer was younger
let me used a version of needle people
on him which we know as hypnotic spell
which saw Allah me insert a needle into
killers brain and effectively program
him not to commit certain actions or pre
program responses to various situations
and as such if kilowatts who resist he
would be struck down with crippling fear
forcing him to do whatever Allah me had
pre-programmed and finally Allah me is
also no stranger to using manipulation
on himself with his famed body
alteration where once again he imbues
nails with aura but sticks them into
himself and manipulates some body into a
different physical construct a disguise
that he is allegedly able to keep up for
around 5 hours at most although he has
noted that it is incredibly painful to
invoke but this actually brings up a
rather good point
in that the typical thought in regards
to manipulation is to place someone else
under your control
but the manipulation of oneself can
actually result in some pretty limit
breaking techniques and for an example
of this we will now turn to shall knock
of the phantom troop now his whole
gimmick is very very similar to that of
Allah me which shall knocks hearts who
being known as black voice which grants
him two antennae that can be stuck into
a target with the same theory behind you
his needles except that shall knock
knees to control his targets through a
mobile phone type device now due to this
being much more restrictive than LME's
manipulation jean arc is granted far
greater control of his targets and he
can even set them into an autopilot mode
however this is also the key to shinnok
self manipulation as if he places an
antenna on himself providing an
instruction and then sets himself to
autopilot mode then it allows him to
push his physical limits resulting in a
significant or output boost and
devastating physical abilities with the
help of said aura however it does come
with a gigantic risk being the ones he
has engaged in autopilot mode he cannot
disengage until his task is being
completed which is a very very high-risk
high-reward scenario but it does also
come with another benefit which is
providing shaun arc and immunity to any
other manipulation hearts or other users
which was exceptionally relevant at one
time during the Chimera ant arc because
manipulation operates on a first-come
first-serve basis so once a target has
been captured by one manipulator it
cannot be captured by another then again
manipulation need not necessarily be so
potent or sinister and in fact the large
majority of manipulators take a much
more simplistic approach to their
abilities such as bays for example the
condition to activate her heart soon
owners instant lava is simply to kiss
her target which causes them to become
instantly infatuated with her to the
point where they are willing to follow
her every command for a total of three
hours so it's a very simple activation
cost for a very modest amount of control
with that said it is possible that there
are other conditions attached to this
hot sue as in the viz translation base
makes a point of saying that she can
make a manservant out of anyone that she
steals a kiss from with instant lover
implying via the word manservant that
the target must be male and that the
kiss more than likely needs to be
non-consensual and then there's also the
obvious that the kiss may need to
involve lip contact which is very
restrictive when you think about it
because there are unlikely to be many
nin veterans that would easily allow
such close contact even for someone like
BAE's now as for one person who Roth
foolishly did being scuola he is also a
basic manipulator who controls a
glorious pack of dogs under the
condition that he takes great care of
them so scuola has effectively sold his
services to his dogs in exchange for
their enhanced services which is you
know it's an interesting deal what I
will say at this point though is that
pretty much every ability I've gone over
thus far is an example of coercive
manipulation which very simply
manipulators engaging in this brand of
power gain total control over their
targets quite simple but as I stated in
the intro there are indeed other brands
the first of which being solicitation
which isn't necessarily what the name
implies it to be actually but
essentially abilities of this type of
manipulation leave their targets
freewill intact but place a condition
upon them which will generally work in
favor of the manipulator and a more
modern example of this would be the
Guardian and beast of 9th Prince
Hulkenberg which is capable of rewriting
and thus manipulating the memory of its
target and furthermore you could also
maybe call ill amis hypnotic spell a
form of solicitation given that it left
kilowatt with his own free will but also
gave him a set of conditions to live by
until the removal of the needle in his
brain although having said that there is
probably also a great argument to be
made that hypnotic spell is more of a
pseudo coercive ability the definite
which is a heart so that traps a target
into a situation where they have no
choice but to relinquish control of
their body or to enact a manipulators
command and a more solid example of this
can be seen in yet another Guardian and
beast but this time of 12th Prince
mama-se who has the infamous are you
free giant mouse thing which repeatedly
asked a target if they are free until
they responds with it yes at which point
a favor is asked of the target which
usually involves the murder of everyone
around them which the target is then
forced to carry out so hypnotic spell
could quite possibly be a pseudo
coercive ability as well because it
tends to force Killa into a situation
whereby he has no choice but to enact
enemy's commands in any case the final
brands we know of is the tricky sounding
diffusive induction type which rather
sadly has not been technically fleshed
out but it has been described as
minimally coercive but capable of
influencing a large number of people
rather than a singular target and yet
another nen baseless time-being 8th
Prince Alice Alice was defined as being
in this category and it basically had
the effect of emitting smoke which when
breathed in will gradually sway the
opinion of that individual into one that
favors Prince Alice Alan so it's kind of
like forcing them in a coercive way but
I honestly find it much more similar to
solicitation whereby the based is simply
manipulating opinion but say according
to Takashi it is a diffusive induction
type and maybe very maybe we'll get a
proper definition of that in the future
and that's enough of pure manipulation
for now because no video covering this
brand of Nan would be complete without
giving some time to mr. Moore
who is one of the finest manipulators in
the series now if the element can be
described as the most powerful pure
manipulator that we know of the moral is
certainly one of the most powerful
splash manipulators meaning that he
incorporates it into a hot soup with two
other affinities being transmutation and
emission to perform the ability deep
purple and this allows malt craft and
control a maximum 216 smoky constructs
however with this many moral has limited
control over them whereas if the number
is compressed to around 50 and he can
wield them with complex actions as well
I'm not going to get into the whole
transmutation argument in this video
because I covered it in the transmuter
one but basically what moral does is he
emits a core Evora he then transmutes
more if his aura into smoke wraps at
around that core and issues commands to
the resulting constructive eye of the
core through manipulation
however Laurel can also perform much
more simplistic actions as well such as
smoky Jail whereby he just traps a
target in a dome of transmuted and
manipulated smoke quite a powerful one
as well with even absurdly powerful
figures such a shape of being unable to
penetrate it without condensing himself
into a series of particle size
life-forms but in essence moral really
is the prime example of an individual
who has not only mastered manipulation
but also brilliantly incorporated it
into a significantly more complex series
of Honsou that go far beyond what we've
seen shown by any pure manipulators and
gives him this supreme sense of
versatility now moving on to other
squash users and in fact manipulation is
pretty much a staple invocation in
regards to controlling any type of Nan
beast or name constructs such as net
rows 100 type Guan Yin Bodhisattva an
uncle Sokka soirée shoots disembodied
hands as well as raises 14 Devils and
look care you get it any heart su that
involves controlling an end construct
absolutely has to invoke manipulation
with the exception of specialists
generated abilities of course but
another interesting fellow I'd like to
highlight is a very recent addition to
the hunt hunter cast being zacchara
custard and I think that he's important
to dwell on for a bit because he focuses
on using manipulation to control his own
blood and wield it as something of a
deadly weapon which is nice and
different to what we've explored thus
far as the wider use of manipulation
focuses on controlling living things or
imitating living things are even
manipulating the use of themselves but
this is a very basic but very effective
invocation of manipulation because it
does not seem to come with any great
restrictions in regards to nen although
because zacchara is using his own blood
for practical reasons he does need to
carry an eye
with him at all times and of course
Sakura also can't afford to have mass
quantities of blood leave his body for
too long because he will obviously do a
bit of the old death but as for another
famous manipulator according to the hunt
hunt data book Shou poof himself was a
natural manipulator evidence of which
can be seen both the Beelzebub and body
reconstruction han-soo although his more
signature abilities being the cocoon and
spiritual message powers consist of
unknown affinities and it's not out of
the question to hypothesize that they do
involve manipulation especially with
spiritual message because it focuses on
identifying a person's psychological
state and acting accordingly as well as
blatant hypnosis and you know what even
the cocoon power seems very much like it
could be manipulating bodies of targets
to transform them into a chimera and and
even grant them net abilities and
actually come to think of it I really
don't see any other explanation for this
unless poof was a specialist which he
certainly is not but then we also have a
cargo whose main ability uses
conjuration actually but he has the
notable hearts who that allows him to
control corpses much like Gilliam II
although a cargo has a much more
unpleasant restriction meaning that he
has to insert himself into said corpse
which sounds fun Owen to cap off our
manipulators apparently Xue XI is also a
natural manipulator so good on him but
in essence manipulation is probably the
most straightforward sounding known
affinity however it's actually full of
absurd subtlety and yawns and oddly
enough manipulation is actually one of
the more foundational uses of now it
certainly doesn't have to be used on its
own and I would argue that the best uses
we've seen are in combination with other
disciplines but then again there are
also figures I kill me or Sherlock who
are just too damn powerful to deny the
potential of pure manipulation as well
but what do you guys think please to
leave your thoughts in the comments
below and if you're keen for small hunt
onto content then please do go and check
out some of my other videos or even
subscribe to the channel for regular
Hunter hunter glory delivered straight
into your YouTube feed but for now this
has been the new old review and I'll see
you next time